falcon of the millennium empire arc is
really really good hit the music
oh
[Music]
every single time i sit down to read
berserk i'm left both amazed and
devastated amazed by the sheer depth of
the series narrative and artwork
devastated by the reality that this will
likely never get the adaptation it
deserves an anime but do you know what's
more devastating forgetting your
passwords and all that other important
information you need when online i'm
someone who uses the internet a lot and
i mean a lot but i'm also super busy and
do everything i can to avoid potential
headaches i am always after products
that help me streamline my process
alongside ensuring i feel in control of
my data regardless of whether i'm at my
pc on my phone or using another device
that's where dashlane has really changed
things for me it does both it stores all
of my passwords my payment info and all
my personal data in a secure place that
only i have access to with just a click
dashlane auto fills in all the data for
me on every site with ease seriously i
could be taking in the beautiful sites
in the middle of nowhere and still log
in to crunchyroll in one click to remind
myself ugly things still exist in this
world while there are other password
managers available dashlane consistently
ranks at the very best thanks to its
patented security technology and machine
learning regardless of your device or
browser no matter where you are it makes
every shopping experience a one-click
checkout and stores all of your
passwords so you're never locked out of
an account best of all it even provides
a vpn for streaming content and secure
browsing that's a lot of features
seriously i really recommend you give it
a try and you can do so for free on your
first device by going to dashlane.com
forward slash tn mark 50 and if you use
code tn mark 50 you can also get 50 off
if you choose to upgrade to one of their
paying plants
last month we left things off with the
black swordsman party looking to secure
a ship with which they wish to use to
facilitate their travel to skellig the
island where elephant is by sea this is
where both main parties guts's and
griffiths meet without knowing who is
who
dramatic irony hell yes isidro means
mule and they both develop a funny
rivalry while shiroke meets sonja
becoming fast friends in the process
sonia offers shitake to come with them
but ultimately shooter k declines
funnily enough during this two isidro
meets a knight as he fights with the
pirate port this knight is obviously
azan after taking the blame for
superconfirence's leaving of the holy
chain knights i've elected to henceforth
call him totally not as an the first
portion of this section largely deals
with lady farani's desire to help her
friends solve a rather persistent issue
the acquisition of a ship with which to
sail to their desired destination all
the while superco has his own issues he
needs to deal with but i'll get to him
in just a second with farni's throughout
this journey she's transformed from a
self-obsessed confused and delusional
girl full of hatred and sadistic
tendencies to a strong young woman
slowly coming to terms with reality
beyond the scope of many all the while
showing a warmth within her that's
unmatched by many if not all of the
party and it's a testament to her
character that this warmth and care she
shows towards kaska and the desire she
gets to broaden her horizons with magic
gets shelved or put on the back burner
indefinitely for the express purposes of
helping her friends acquire a ship even
if that means that moving on with their
journey without her it's an interesting
plot point in its own right introducing
us to the broader family and the
struggle for power and respect that
dwells there but as i mentioned it too
serves and executes brilliantly the
function of highlighting just how far
lady fairness has come as a human being
in this story furthermore as a quick
aside i really like the role magic as a
concept is playing in this tale it
represents the change that's taking
place both figuratively and literally
inside of her opening herself up to the
possibilities that she might be able to
change and for her seeing the results of
magic would act as somewhat of a
validation for that change however now
she seems to have lost her nerve opting
to be of use in the only way she sees
herself to be of use to others as a pawn
providing a ship to her friends however
in making that decision ironically and
appropriately she unconsciously
demonstrates that exact change she
wishes to see within herself by making
that very choice leveraging her status
as an aristocrat marrying herself off
and while guts and co in quite a cute
and familial fashion moved to confront
her about this to rescue her from
herself the monsters they once saw at
the shores during the last section start
to emerge all the while another obstacle
makes himself known before standing in
their way
ding ding ding it's serpaco versus guts
round two while guts is all muscle and
tenacity serpaco is all strategy and
tactics and fittingly this acts as a
great lesson for isidro as he watches
the conflict once upon a time he was
taught the value of understanding one's
shortcomings as a fighter in a fight and
circo is the physical manifestation of
that very idea to its extreme but
ignoring ysidra for a second the story
of this fight is a profound one that's
beautiful in its depth of character
introspection conflict fights and
contests between two individuals in
manga and indeed story are great because
of the contrast and indeed information
the readers or viewers can glean from
that contrast you need look no further
than goku and vegeta in dragon ball or
more abstractly luffy versus the world
government in one piece when two forces
clash they highlight their respective
differences in the prior two examples
many of the encounters these contests
share serve to highlight the struggle
between good versus evil however with
regard serpico and guts in this instance
the contrast and conflict doesn't serve
to highlight the struggle of good versus
evil necessarily but instead something
far more nuanced and fundamental to each
respective character that speaks to the
soul of their respective designs in
berserk gods represent struggle and
tenacity in the face of overwhelming
terror and destruction serpaco on the
other hand as he puts it adapts to his
circumstances to fill a role that is
presented to him to accept what is
before him even if it is unreasonable
and so unbeknownst to me as this fight
unraveled it revealed itself to be a
classic clash of ideologies not good
versus evil necessarily again but more
so an irresistible force guts versus the
immovable object of serpaco however only
one here seems to be struggling with
something and it isn't guts addressing
gods as someone he serpico who once
turned a blind eye to everything can now
not simply ignore and as a result fears
what might happen if he discovers more
about himself and continues to change in
this party what that change might
manifest as within him and so
interestingly while lydie farney's story
is all about her desire for something
more to change herself serpico's story
seems to be more about his desire to
remain the same to not change into
someone who can't turn a blind eye like
he used to he doesn't trust guts
entirely and that scares him the fight
itself ends about as fast as it begins
however and while there were some
tremendous ideas on display with some
wonderful introspection from serpico
guts emerges the victor and the panels
both leading up to and during this fight
were spectacular there's such a
wonderful sense of motion with each
panel beautifully and perfectly
connecting the threads of surprise
thoughts to the motions of his sword
more so perhaps than any other fight in
this series i really felt the rhythm of
this one like a dance the fight worked
with the story being told each more
emphatic and effective because of each
other following this event gut serpico
and the team storm the banquet hall
liddy farney's and our family are
residing within just in the nick of time
too to make the save and perhaps this is
a coincidence but i may have noticed
that there were some similarities to how
farnis was saved by serpico when
compared to guts's saves with casca way
back when instead of a flash of black
there was a flash of white before
serpico appears by farnace's side
protecting her from harm however unlike
the previous encounters where farnese
felt like a burden while guts was
hacking tiger monsters in tremendous
fashion into bits and serpico went to
take down the source of the trouble in
front of her family and indeed her
companions farnese takes down a tiger
using a magical item proving to herself
that she is capable of the sort of
change she desires to see in herself and
as a short plot beat i really like this
something i did neglect to mention the
prior video was a certain encounter guts
has with a particular member of a
significant group you might have heard
of him the god hand as we saw in the
conviction arc conrad one of the godhand
members was responsible for the plague
in midland all the while slan the girly
god hand member was responsible for the
orgy club nina was part of and during
the events of this arc's first half you
may have noticed that we met with her
again manifesting herself via troll
intestines tempting guts to use his
bellit and become an apostle the god
hands are always present in this story
and for a reason that's more than likely
going to be clear in the not so distant
future everything they've done so far
even putting everything in place for
griffith's incarnation ceremony seems to
be connected to griffith himself but
slan's presence here not only serves to
make this obvious but also to introduce
us to something even more terrifying
enter
[Music]
the sword of actuation skull knight
sword made of bellets otherwise known as
the most metal concept for a weapon in
the entire series this is a weapon
that's been created by skull knight that
has been specifically crafted to kill in
humans the concept of this sword is
absolutely insane and abundantly clear
why skull knight is the main enemy of
the godhand members it can basically cut
through reality reaching even the
deepest layers of the astral world you
might remember the abyss that sucked in
all the inhumans way back in like the
black swordsman arc yeah the sword can
get you even there if you want and this
is how skull knight helps guts out in
that instance but man we haven't seen
yet just how [ __ ] powerful this sword
can actually be
okay so this part is sort of a
transitional period between the scene we
just finished with the party and the
next big one we're greeted by yet more
stunningly and distressingly grotesque
artwork courtesy of miura himself
massive page spreads illustrating the
invasion of this land by the monsters
that emerged from the shadows crocodiles
tigers monsters and soldiers all the
same it's quite ominous and basically
our takeaway at this point should be
leaving this village will be no easy
task but fret not because roderick is a
badass who sets them up with a ship just
like that however before boarding the
ship they noticed that the harbour is
infested with monsters hundreds of them
shirakai effectively tells guts to step
down and to leave it to her as they
stand guard they bide their time
together as shooter k becomes a raging
inferno monster leaving the surrounding
area as scorched earth destroying every
single enemy available to her i like
this not just for the cool visuals but
also the team effort it took to pull
this off it's nice however it's not
enough as tons more massive monsters
suddenly appear with guts going into
berserker mode and this magic man i
won't even attempt to embarrass myself
by trying to pronounce the name of
appears impressed by godzilla's ability
and his armor and this is where things
get a little cool shitake reaches into
guts's psyche to create this conscious
state where guts gets to use the
berserker armor while fully in control
of his faculties thus creating a sort of
nice symbiotic relationship between
these two characters that were once sort
of at odds with each other moreover
specifically i love this mechanism
within the suit itself it has direct
ties to the cracks in the blade chapters
themes way back during the conviction
arc to use the suit to its fullest
potential is akin to embracing hatred
itself which if we look to the cracks in
the blade chapter we can see this is
akin to being selfish meaning the
hardest way the most courageous way is
to do what's best for those you love and
for those that depend on you that's what
makes for the correct moral choice in
this series and in essence is what i
love most about guts as a character this
internal struggle he's flawed has
desires endurance to do the right thing
even if it's the hardest path forward i
mean he's a true hero again this is a
terrific piece of development for
shirakay too since her introduction
she's been encouraged by one person or
another to have faith in those she
fights with in this case guts time and
again she recognizes the circumstances
guts finds himself in as impossible to
overcome and yet he still persists on
living on struggling forward this
fundamentally changes her and in this
scene we see just how much she has
changed willing to follow gutz's rash
plan of action placing all of her faith
into him when he requests it it's a
wonderful team effort from both guts and
shitake that speaks to both their
characters perfectly shitake is required
to shoulder the mental toil while guts
absorbs the physical punishment this is
all to say that this fight was really
cool and honestly i was expecting it to
end here
however it didn't
and as it turns out this fight we just
concluded our discussion on was actually
just a warm-up fight to something i
never in a million years saw coming
zod
zod makes the last second save and now
he's teaming up with guts i thought
about this one long and hard and a large
number of questions concerning this
occurrence stepped into my mind is zod
an entity that aligns himself with
individuals like guts and griffith when
they fight with full conviction against
the particular force does he have a camp
with which he chooses to fight with or
is it random and if it's not random what
dictates what his choices are
narratively there's this idea of destiny
in this story i've explored a number of
times and instead of retreading that
motivating factor for the millionth time
i'd like to look at what the story has
physically shown us thus far with
regards to him specifically that being
the number of times we've seen zyde prop
up therein and use that to derive some
sort of conclusion or at the very least
a theory we can firstly consider that
this foe he's facing off against with
guts is a shared enemy of both guts and
griffith so on the face of that alone it
doesn't seem contradictory to anything
we've seen from him recently ish one of
griffith's main critiques of most people
when asked about friendship was quite
cold and detached he has his dream he's
going to achieve it and he meant that in
the most honest and straightforward way
he could there are a few moments in the
story where griffith gets to speak
frankly and introspectively with us as
an audience to see so i see this
instance as pivotal not only for him but
how his relationship with guts will
ultimately conclude down the road you
just don't say stuff like this without
planning for it to service the
conclusion of an arc later on down the
line from this scene he cites that he
couldn't really have a friend beyond
someone that too chose to chase their
dream irrespective of who or what stood
in their way that then and only then
when another would pursue their dream in
full mind body and spirit could he
respect them enough to see them as an
equal worthy of friendship and bouncing
off of that idea presented by griffith
back during the golden age i wonder if
the fact griffith is so inhuman in his
devotion to his individual gold i wonder
if that is the mechanism by which he
seems to have an allyship or connection
with someone like zot and furthermore
why when guts falters he either faces
zod head on or receives help from his
metaphysical opposite in this world
skull knight there's a scene where zod
speaks to sonja for a short while within
which sonia acts as a proxy through
which a question can be posed towards
zod concerning his destiny it's a choice
he needs to make it is and i quote to
again battle a sword that cuts your own
flesh or to make it your own weapon when
i saw this quote i sort of leaned back
into my chair and try to absorb the
meaning of this beyond the obvious
implications prophecy is clearly
something that plays a pivotal role in
this world and indeed this story when i
look at zod's contribution to the series
i think okay so he helps guts but then
he also doesn't he's sympathetic towards
guts but then he tries to kill him while
also helping his arch nemesis griffith
the quote directed towards zod in this
instance obviously speaks to a prime
directive he seems to be at odds with in
his mind and indeed with those around
him of similar nature as a monster he
like everyone else similar to him feels
this desire to squash guts and devour
him when he's weakest he is a marked
human after all however he chooses to
deny that much the same way ganeshka has
chosen his own path resulting in one of
the absolute best that i mean best
two-page spreads of not just the series
but any comic or any image i might have
ever seen i mean look at it i want this
as a poster never in all of my life have
i seen such incredible dynamic powerful
artwork in a manga but that too got me
thinking about what this means regarding
the second half of that quote from sonia
that being
or to make the sword your own weapon
naturally this refers to guts in this
instance zod and gods in the heat of
battle chose to work alongside one
another to strike down ganeshka as
shared foe before going their separate
ways at the end with plenty of symbolic
gestures showing the growth guts has
undergone as a character for if he were
to have followed hatred he would have no
doubt died there and then which makes me
wonder if this quote can be extrapolated
upon and viewed through the lens of guts
and griffith's relationship specifically
there seemed to me at least to be a lot
of parallels between this quote zod and
guts's time spent on the pages of this
manga and so i wonder if a similar
choice might present itself forgot
somewhere down the line if we look all
the way back to the golden age following
his desertion of the band of the hawk he
left in search of his own dream in other
words he had no conviction at the time
which if we cast our minds back to the
chapter campfire of dreams is exactly
the topic of which he felt alienated by
and fast forward again once he lost
everything upon his return he gained a
tremendous hatred and by extension a
desired goal through the conviction arc
we then learned that this desire he had
to kill griffith was an entirely vapid
cowardly and selfish desire which flew
in the face of his true dream that being
to save kaska and in this moment it's
that exact impulse or dream which acts
as his salvation so it makes me wonder
griffith has been a sword which has
wounded guts in the past
will guts like zod had to do here and
now
need to make that same decision a
decision he struggled with since the
start of the story will guts be forced
to make a decision not to kill griffith
but to instead fight alongside him for
some greater cause this seems like the
natural extreme or destination of this
philosophy the story has been exploring
and what makes sense to me right here
and now i think at this point it's
important to remember that we are only
seeing this story really through the
eyes and experiences of guts for the
most part the most introspection we get
from griffith comes by way of guts's
point of view mostly and the same can be
pretty much said for every other
character which is what makes scenes
like this one sonja shared with zod
prior to his save all the more
interesting and noteworthy we follow
guts's struggle and travels and due to
that it's easy to forget that with
regards to most other characters zod and
griffith included they each have
undergone a tremendous amount of
suffering and struggle in order to
achieve what their own respective goals
are guts denies himself the catharsis of
embracing hatred zod denies himself the
desire to devour guts when he's most
vulnerable and perhaps even griffith the
most alien perspective to us right now
is also ignoring something he desires in
order to achieve his dream
switching gears for a second let's talk
a bit about griffith and his situation
the cushion advancement onto the
battlefield to face the weakened forces
of the holy see army was presented in
quite an unfamiliar fashion to me for
much of it there's virtually no dialogue
to speak of forcing our full attention
on the overwhelming strength of
ganesha's forces things aren't looking
good but griffith and his new band of
the hawks show up in similar fashion as
they did in the golden age to save the
day i thought at the time of reading
this that he would no doubt be looking
to climb the ranks of this new army too
but griffith is 10 steps ahead
apparently he challenges ganeshka to a
fight one-on-one at another location far
from here thus creating a scene wherein
he saves the entire army from certain
destruction this creates a fantastic
morale and rapport between himself and
his subjects to be right off the bat
couple that with the presence of
princess charlotte and this religious
figure and you have for yourself not
just a hero like we saw in golden age
but a full-blown savior in the eyes of
these people griffith has finally become
in many ways a god to these folks and
speaking of godlike fernice progresses
her training on the ship to the astral
plane with some of the most beautiful
page spreads i've seen from miura but
moreover this scene stands alongside one
of my favorite quotes in this arc
i guess even if you force back what was
lost it still won't be the way it was in
this short but brilliant quote there's
call backs to both cracks in the blade
and also kaska's attempted suicide in
the golden age arc and funnily enough it
all stems from what guts perceives koska
to be to him at that very moment in time
there's no question that she's an
enormous burden the likes of which even
guts on his own would struggle to handle
and we are talking about someone who can
handle pretty much anything it seems
she's terrified of him she's effectively
an entirely different person void of
speech or really any form of
communication to him what's left he must
be thinking as she falls overboard and
guts jumps to save her unlike during the
golden age where he catches her she
slips through the fingers of his false
limb and falls before needing to be
rescued afterwards upon reflection gut
shares this profound quote that speaks
to the conflict in his mind concerning a
question that he was posed in a prior
section at the beach they are traveling
to pug's home in the hopes that casket
can be restored to her former self but
what if she doesn't want to change back
what if she can't what if you can't
force back what was lost what if it will
always be the way that it is now
no do-overs there's a tremendous amount
of sadness in this chapter and an
all-too-familiar sense of hopelessness
to boot the limb that once reached out
and saved casket from falling is now
missing replaced with a weapon a bringer
of death without the ability to save
what's most important to him anymore
it's a wonderful piece of symbolism that
caps off this section of the story with
a grim reminder that overcoming one's
demons isn't as simple as many stories
might lead you to believe this isn't a
disney film or a ghibli epic and despite
this being a tale of good and evil
fairies and dragons zombies and monsters
it's also a story detailing a realistic
struggle one man has to undergo for the
sake of others not just during a pivotal
part of his life wherein he learns a
single lesson to overcome a singular
trauma but instead this is a part of him
that he has now learned to live with and
manage for possibly the rest of his life
the beast that dwells within him is
there alive and well perhaps never to
truly leave him in peace of all the
demons that have followed god throughout
this long winding and harrowing journey
it's himself the beast in black
his darker tendencies that will force
him to run for the rest of his life
perhaps
further adding another layer of interest
and nuance to this growing quagmire of a
problem he's faced with guts seems to
find himself entrenched in an unsolvable
situation but at least for the time
being he still has his allies his
friends a surprisingly effective and
helpful newcomer to the party comes in
the form of rodrik with his incredible
nautical experience coming in
immeasurably handy to ensure their safe
passage across the sea it's a scene that
reinforces just how much guts needs
these people he surrounded himself with
thank heavens for them for without he
would almost certainly be lost in every
sense of the word but okay so that's
what's going on with guts's side of the
coin what about with griffith in prior
videos i reacted to and discussed
griffith's return to the physical world
exploring the massive changes his very
presence implies in isolation due to
this presence his being alive and well
once again it means both mortal and
astral worlds are getting closer and
many creatures and monsters that once
only existed in the first layer of the
astral plane are now invading the mortal
realm as i alluded to a moment ago this
is because griffith's newest incarnation
shouldn't exist and therefore breaks the
rules and laws of nature and the world
itself he's a super powerful astral
angel in a physical body with the likes
of scotland even going as far as to say
that the only way that they can stop him
is to also exist beneath the limbo that
defines the natural order of things make
sense of that if you can once
resurrected anew griffith formed this
new band of the falcon or band of the
hawk as it's referred to in this manga
that i'm reading composed of humans from
both midland and the cushion empire as
well as demons from the astral world and
so with this brand new army he begins
his offensive against the cushion
emperor ganeshka an incredibly powerful
apostle in his own right one that
negates the authority of the god hand
and wants to become a greater being too
it's pretty wild and man when these two
guys clash it gets even wilder in ways
never before committed to the pages of
this manga and i'm not just saying that
these chapters made such a huge
impression on me so much so that i would
honestly make it comparable to that of
the eclipse during the golden age i
don't know if that's a common opinion or
not but it's absolutely how i felt
whilst reading it because
this is it the culmination of griffith's
pursuit it feels like the beginning of
something entirely and profoundly new
prophetically this battle between
ganeshka and griffith ends up becoming
the fight that both literally and
figuratively sets the foundations for
griffith's rule on a figurative level
ganeshka presents such a profoundly
incomprehensible threat to not just
midland but the world at large so much
so that any individual that could
possibly topple this monster would no
doubt become a divine figure eligible to
rule the world in the eyes of those that
witness this struggle and i mean that
both in the eyes of man and monster
alike it's a total unification
poetically and physically this is the
ultimate vision of the kingdom griffith
hat this battle not only is iconic for
protecting the world but also as the
first instance for both humans and
demons collaborating and helping each
other in this effort this is the
eradication of war and the birth of a
new era the transformation kanishka
undergoes is unlike any i've seen in any
manga it's horrifying while also
managing to make me feel exceptionally
insignificant and small as a reader the
sense of scale miura manages to capture
in these drawings is not only beautiful
in a horrific sense but also vital for
this battle's final moments to work
effectively the greater the threat
ganeshka can convince us he's capable of
the more incredible the people of
midland and by extension we as an
audience feel griffith's conquest will
be furthermore the battle literally sets
the foundations for griffith's rule by
physically acting as the catalyst that
drags the worlds of the astral and
mortal realms together in a convincing
fashion creating a kingdom the likes of
which only exists in the minds of
griffith and children's storybooks the
result is something so incredibly
outlandish and ethereal yet oddly
fitting for a series that has dealt with
so much grotesque realism this is a
gorgeous moment of fantasy and respite a
culmination of everything griffith has
ever wanted it seems and the most
impressive thing is it's all conveyed
with no dialogue this is like attempting
a world record and being so confident in
your abilities to succeed in that effort
that you do it blindfolded this singular
choice set this battle apart from every
other clash in the series on a
fundamental level for me it felt as
though i was watching one of those
intense epic battles on film like lord
of the rings that helms deep with
knishka's terror and fear of losing to
griffith with his fear of the invasion
he sees with his fear of the feelings
griffith's presence forces him to feel
it leads him to make the strategic and
rash decisions that on the surface made
for a tremendously imposing adversary
all the while unconsciously playing
right into the hands of prophecy
unwittingly and with ganishka being one
of the few demonic figures that actually
pushes against face failing it makes me
wonder how much control if any guts and
his party of friends possesses in
reality skull knight effectively told
guts that he has to defy destiny but
perhaps his efforts to defy destiny are
actually part of a greater plan and
that's what makes this such an
incredible story you have no idea which
way it's going to go our next berserk
video will unfortunately be our last as
it will bring us to the untimely end of
this exceptional and i do mean
exceptional series
hopefully i'll see you all there but
until then i've been tolling up mark and
thank you so much for
[Music]
and let it watching
down
[Applause]